老师们来吧
爱你什么歌呢
那我们先大声一点
让我们的原唱出来可以吗
♪ 嗨 ♪
♪ 如果你突然打了个喷嚏 ♪
♪ 那一定就是我在想你 ♪
♪ 如果半夜被手机吵醒啊 ♪
♪ 那是因为我关心 ♪
♪ 常常想你说的话是不是别有用心 ♪
♪ 明明很想相信 ♪
♪ 却又忍不住怀疑 ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ 在你的心里 ♪
♪ 我是否就是唯一爱 ♪
♪ 就是我常烦着你 ♪
♪ 欢迎我邪 ♪
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多盛点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿 ♪
♪ 幸福一定 ♪
♪ Hello ♪
♪ 大家好吗 ♪
♪ Put your hands up ♪
♪ 喜欢在你的臂弯里胡闹 ♪
♪ 你的世界是一座城堡 ♪
♪ 在大头贴画满心号 ♪
♪ 贴在手机上 ♪
♪ 对你微笑 ♪
♪ 常常想我说的话 ♪
♪ 你是否听得进去 ♪
♪ 你很想生气 ♪
♪ 却又止不住想 ♪
♪ Emo ♪
♪ oh仔 ♪
♪ 我的心里奥丁真的就是唯一爱 ♪
♪ 就是有我常赖着你 ♪
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你一天多一点 ♪
♪ 慢慢地累积 ♪
♪ 感觉两人的世界就能够贴近一点 ♪
♪ 所有的朋友baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我们真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ 白首帅一点想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
♪ 多一点才会慢慢发现 ♪
♪ 因为你让我心甘情愿 ♪
哦吼掌声鼓励三弟王心凌